flashback and this was in October of 2013
my second to last game I did have a start
after that in St Louis it also did not
go well but just for my own defense I did
not start that game against San Jose
Henrik lanquist went in and was bad
and then I got to go in my first game
of the season in San Jose the backup
goendale plates before so then between the
first and the second no I tried to get out
of the way of the camera person I thought there
was a mat there it wasn't so I started slipping
basically ruin my edges right so I don't like
getting my skate sharpened in game I had to
take all the tape around my ankles off give my
skates to the trainer quickly get back dressed
and then I went on the ice just for a quick throw
at the start of the second I wasn't even playing
and I literally like could not stop and then
this happened I couldn't catch the edge with
the left foot which would have made me go back
to the right and uh hurdle put it between his
legs but no that was a fantastic play Hey over
2 million views on YouTube and what I love most
now that's the number one gift people comes back
to me oh hey you got hurdled yes I know what a
burn thank you like I didn't know I'm fine with
it I gave the guy a sign stick after the season
I was like please enjoy it he was 19 years old
the Penguins they're just trying to kill as much
time off it went in oh my goodness unbelievable
you don't see that every day that is incredible
I certainly have never seen that before not live
anyway Letang has it he goes back to malan and
Malin can handle this back pass it goes off the
blade and into the back of the net and Whoever
touched this Puck last for the counties is going
to get the goal unbelievable I think that says
it all right there look at a Flames player in the
Toronto bench I don't think that's AJ and I think
we got penalties coming after that that's the old
Sesame Street one of these things is not like the
other k y tried to engineer a pre- deadline
deal there and moved rear the Toronto Sterling
and taking it for fny Pon scores broken soken I
believe he loses his blade this is a great catch
from our truck downstairs look at that it hits
the toe of his right foot so now he can't stand
up he stays down there as you can see no Edge
no Edge that's a helpless feeling power PL with
red they mo from 18 they're going to get another
one here a high sticking penalty it's loive front
scores they were trying to give it away to get
the whistle but drewan scores oh boy now you got
another Power Play coming up that that's a play
you can't stop what a smart play to just keep it
alive Colton there I think was surprised that this
was coming through to him but he did a great job
look at drewan at the last second Just Adjust
and realize he's got an open shot away looking
wrap around instead to lazan Carri a shoot score
[Applause] yes sir 7.1 to go a magical bounce on
a Saturday night at smackville carier Let it Fly
and it fluttered over the shoulder of soken hits
the Stick of Mayfield breaks it in half and then
it goes over the shoulder of sokin look at the
bench what a goal as back by middle step to Dalene
scor off the stick in front of the net Dalene took
the shot and I believe off a hawks player into the
back of the net and it's three nothing Buffalo for
the Chicago Blackhawks just stick out their stick
they're the ones that redirected and pass their
goenda Hawks Gutman down the right side
will drop it back backand pass to the slap
by Phillips intercepted I don't think he was
totally out of the box there when he touched
that Puck and that's why they're going to blow it
down yeah yeah he wasn't out of the box his feet
were still in the box when he plays this puck so
dolls is going back into the box here here comes
the puck there he is he's still inside the box and
you can't do that Jaws again confidently plays the
buck he takes a shot at the empty net and it was
deflected down here's heer he shoots and blocked
do was going for it if it didn't get deflected
he had a shot he could shoot it now teing in
front his shot is blocked by barov burino drives
it wide to the empty net Tierney's got it again
he centers he sure shoots it's blocked Mercer
poking out of no another whack at the empty net
this clock is winding down on the Panthers and
finally Marino stuffs it in to make it four to
one the insurance go as the devils are going to
slay Florida here it's the braks throwing snow at
peruna obey cubel twister off the front carams in
Nicholas obey cubel gets a friendly bounce off of
fault it's 2-1 good things happen when you throw
pucks to the net this one is a perfect example why
he just gets it fires it on a sharp angle off the
right foot of Justin B the goalie unsuspecting the
defenseman unsuspecting and there's the goal looks
toward the net big shoot saved by Ric up into the
netting it goes I might have got the crossbar as
well back Ric afterwards turned around and kind
of rubbed the crossbar a little bit and said thank
you Thompson Horvat middle of the ice turn shoots
off the crossbar good look four patch just hit
the top iron as Nelson settles things down moves
it back to McMahon backman for Hallberg he's got
been W up Hallberg Tri a goal score oh one hander
how about that it's four nothing P this homor
with his first goal in 19 games you'd never
know it yeah MIT Marner has all our reactions
hello that's a hell of a goal there by Bergie
that's why he's my favorite player in the NHL so
um big goal by him now for Pon SL L and Scar set
up beautifully a power play goal and it's 1-1
looks back across for naner feeds it back for
marer in shoot scores Mitch mner power play goal
the Leafs have taken the lead here in the second
period and naner got the worst of that celebration
many good looks and a big hit to finish it off by
Mitch barter AR with a shot blocked by Caro armana
battle for the puck trying to find it it's loose
he goes goia knocks it home there's the block
by Gerard and there's the puck sitting in the
skates of cogat then armia kicks it I'm not even
sure if he knows he kicked it but he kicked it
forward and then Gerard doesn't pick it up as
it comes across the front of Y Tak It Away by
Josh BR and forced up Andre blurry way out of the
net going to try to get back all the way back how
you look by Gary Smith from the 1970s there oh
they're loving it here the only thing really the
fans at the XL Energy Center had to cheer about
tonight the other Five Guys on the ice right now
oh my gosh Mark audre what are you doing right
now there a lot of goalies out on the ice right
now besides number 29 till he gets back between
the pipes never a dull moment when that man's in
net heavy snow and wind have been pounding the
Buffalo area we've got the Panthers and the Red
Wings subbing in tonight mother nature doesn't
care about your plans Biz just the way it goes
we're going to call this game as well because
our crew is stuck there if if you're sick of us
now just wait opportunity Oh short Ed goal wow
what a shot Reinhardt breaks the ice this that
guy can shoot it Dy Captain they needed to do
something tonight not a [Music] [Applause] boy
settled down by Joseph he's checked LOL kicks the
pl in Fr of the goal there's a pass to sh scores
what an individual effort by linol though to kick
that puck out front to hubero 13th goal the season
for Joo Sharon goic he's tied his total last year
with the New Jersey Devils they move it across
there be the shot it's deflected in front bounces
over the head of curri all the way out here zamula
SC what a strange goal everybody thought the puck
was at the side of the net zabula found it fired
it into the empty cage it's a power play goal
one one there was only one person on the whole
ice that knew where the puck was and it was Jer
zamula it goes off to the right and everybody is
thinking that the puck is somewhere under mad so
guard yet the only one who saw it was zamula as
the puck went to the sideboards it's not just mad
soard it's actually Philadelphia Flyers players
as well SMA says I'll take a freebie I'll put
it into the middle of the net uh how intently
do we take figer law like the lamp we all have
that look that Alex lion was wearing as he got
ready for yeah I'm looking around at you yeah
we're look yeah you talking to me yeah yeah
we'll make tonight's picks in figer law light
the lamp next hi I'm Brad Maron my favorite
hockey team growing up was the Toronto he assumed
it was going on goal here's a door off heat it up
and flips in on goal that one pinballs its way in
it was shot from the point by Miller and he will
lead the lineup they're all trying to figure out
who scored it the Canucks get the shot from Miller
at the point it goes off one two three different
Columbus players proov being the last of them M
leens can't believe it he's got the glove going
up it's going down it's going everywhere he'll
pick it up at Cent slow down the slot must S one
of the silkiest MS in the National he scored in a
shle like this just two weeks ago and he went top
shelf on that same move everybody watches tape so
here he comes in tries to sneak it by he's Savvy
to that Reinhardt over the Blue Line gives jabarov
5 seconds left in overtime here's Reinhardt on
the doorstep of the back he scores let's go home
baby Sam Reinhardt extends the winning streak
to nine Peanut Butter Jelly Time get the win
here on the road 3 to2 they're NHL leading
27th one goal game their 14th Victory down
low Big R it down to one in he gets all stick
look at how far down he puts his hands over
halfway down on this stick McKinnon knows it
sees it sweet little pass between the legs and
moik just buries that with Scoops that oh that
was barred down into the back of the net here's
Dickinson and he hit the post and on the rebound
it did not cross the line it was on his way right
there and just stops hits the brakes fortunately
for the Sharks one of the newer Hawks Sanford and
that hit the post and then it CED across the line
and out gets it up and around him knocks off the
helmet of Blackwood and off the goal post and out
that's why I think you're seeing Clark toon off
toward the net they score foxa might have got a
piece of it with the Stars on the rush and they
make it to zip and this is going to go right off
the skate of gabov in front who's battling with
faxa but here's the battle along the wall it ends
up right in front of ottawa's bench he's yelling
give me a stick give me a stick so forget gives
him a new one right there St back into the pl if
a Tom hand off doesn't lose a step or an inch
along the wall beats down low s out there and
rs into the net from behind the goal line that is
your goahead goal a fortuitous bounce for Sam G
yeah I'd saying the least here it is here Anderson
catches the glove and finds the corner two1 Evon
that's a tough one for Calgary in there with Hayes
of course having great numbers and a great year in
Springfield against 24 goals in 37 games that puck
is held against the boards and we get a whistle
maybe the puck is in the equipment God I think
it is that's where it went the old hidden park TR
right the old mystery here and there it's in the
capital players pant leg Ethan bear strange event
there
for